و أوتش
[أغنية]
[تصفيق]
و أوتش
[أغنية]
و
يمكننا أن نرى أن الببتيدات
أنها لا تمنع فقط تطور
الفيروس في المختبر أو داخل خلية
النموذج ولكننا تمكنا أيضًا من رؤيته
هنا في ساو كارلوس يمكنها ذلك
تمنع أحد البروتينات
مهم جدا للتطوير
من الفيروس و
و أوتش
ا
[أغنية]
الخطوة الأولى في مسيرة طويلة
في الأساس لأن العملية عندما يكون
يتحدث الناس عن الاكتشاف و
تطوير عقاقير جديدة
إنه طويل جدًا ، فماذا نفعل
يصنع هنا السم على سبيل المثال
حق هذا المكون من السم ليس كذلك
ولا يعتبر السم أحد مكونات
أظهر السم الذي نعمل عليه
نحن في هذا العمل الذي نحن
التي تم تطويرها وبالتالي لديها القدرة على
التنمية هناك ، ثم الحق
الناس مثل هؤلاء الناس في طريق طويل إلى
اتخذنا الخطوات الأولى 1
و أوتش